all right
let's see let's move to this daily wires
reporting the National Hockey League
took some heat over a Tuesday tweet
promoting a transgender and non-binary
hockey tournament and a follow-up
comment asserting trans women are women
trans men are men non-binary identity is
real
the tournament in question the team
trans draft tournament took place over
the weekend in Middleton Wisconsin and
included only trans and non-binary
players
on Tuesday at the NH NHL's official
Twitter account shared several photos
from the tournament along with a
statement showing support for the event
said the NHL is is proud to support this
past weekend's team trans draft
tournament in Middleton Wisconsin this
was the first tournament uh comprised
entirely of transgender and non-binary
players with around 80 folks
participating
and then that's when they responded uh
to someone else saying that trans women
are women trans men are men non-binary
identity is real
what we have to understand is that every
institution and organization at this
point is basically run by blue-haired
liberal women
and gay liberal men like that's every
organization in America is either run by
such or as or as operates as though it
is
okay which is how you get the NHL
tweeting something that it sounds like
it's you know you you imagine a blue
haired 22 year old gender Studies major
saying that and this is what you're
getting from the NHL which used to be
I've never been a hockey fan
but I've always respected hockey at
least as a as a kind of rough and tumble
masculine sport
and even there
tweeting this stuff
trying to appeal to an audience that
will never be their customer base
like the people who
want to hear that kind of thing trans
women are women non-binary identities
are real like the the the the
demographic of people who find that sort
of thing appealing
this is a demographic that is not
watching hockey okay
and that's not even to say that nobody
no liberal identifying person watches
hockey I'm sure there are
but even they like they it's not going
to be the kind of liberal that needs to
hear you say that
you know I love spending the holidays
with my family and one of the ways that
I like to do that is with delicious meat
from good ranchers as a special gift to
my listeners this holiday season good
ranchers is giving away two Black Angus
New York strip steaks free with your
order these are two 12-ounce Steakhouse
quality cuts a 70 value for free and you
don't want to miss this offer because
I'll tell you why well Black Angus
tastes better and is more tender than
any other beef black angus meat is
marbled in such a way that the fat is
distributed thinly and evenly this
marbling gives it a consistent flavor
that you don't get with other meats plus
the Black Angus from good ranchers is
hand cut and trimmed by expert butchers
so you know every piece is going to be
Exquisite go to goodrancers.com Walsh
use code walls to check out for this
special offer that's goodranchers.com
Walsh for two Black Angus New York strip
steaks free with your order good
ranchers American Meat delivered
so this is just these woke
uh institutions committing it's like
it's suicide it's self-destruction
you really don't gain anything from it
they're not they're not going to profit
off of this
and this isn't even a case you know
sometimes you have these these
organizations corporations that will go
woke in response to some sort of
controversy
so it would almost be it would still not
be justifiable but almost be a different
case if you had say I don't know some
NHL player who said something who who
dared to say out loud that um you know
women are women and men are men and then
was getting a lot of heat from it from
from uh from uh the media and then the
NHL responded by saying oh we don't
believe that we believe that trans women
are women
so that would be a case of them trying
to dig themselves out of a hole it would
still be again
unjustifiable and a stupid thing to do
but you understand the motivation anyway
they're just cowardly trying to dig
themselves out of this PR Hole by um by
pandering to the left
but in this case it's an unforced error
like they could have just not tweeted
that you don't need to
no one needed to see you tweet that
the only thing you can hope to do is
alienate the audience you already have
because again you're not going to
attract
whatever audience it finds that kind of
statement really appealing you're not
you're not going to attract them and not
watching hockey
that's why wokeness it really does
especially when it comes to these
corporations it reminds me of lives
think of this the other day
you know that uh
there's a certain kind of parasite it's
like a brain parasite and it's
Toxoplasma something or other that can
infest mice
and when when the mice are infested by
this parasite it causes the mice to be
suicidal actually makes them attracted
to cats and so they will run to their
own death
they will run into the into the the
mouths of a of a waiting cat that's
going to devour them uh they Embrace
their own destruction because that's the
parasite because the parasite really
wants to end up inside the cat and so
this is the the way that it's evolved
it's a really similar thing with with
Wellness I think it causes this kind of
self-destructive Instinct especially in
corporations they just run to their own
destruction
in a very similar kind of way yes
wokeness is a is a brain parasite maybe
the best way to describe it and I'll do
it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you uh on
Monday have a great Thanksgiving
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]